[Music]
clark is in salt lake city hey clark
what's up in your world
hey how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
yeah quick question
so my wife and i are in a little bit of
a car bind
kelly blue book suggested the value of
the car is around 5 600
but the issue is that
it's at the shop and you learn that it's
going to require around four thousand
dollars in repairs to get it good lord
working again did you take it to the
dealer yeah
that is at the dealer yeah because the
check engine light was on yeah and you
know that dealer that's not a good place
to get your car fixed right
you know you know it's double what
everybody else is right
honestly i i've always been someone that
just takes it to the dealer no
well i'm getting ready to help you with
that now you're not
because now you're someone that wants a
better deal than they'll give you so i
want you to get a second opinion on this
from someone else what's wrong with the
car
um
i mean it's only
it's a 2012 102 000 miles the turbo i
guess is out the oil
coolers out
the axle seal
um on the drive side is
leaking
well on a 5000 car we don't worry about
the axle seal you're not going to be
driving it that much longer we certainly
don't care about the turbo well yeah if
you can fix it but i mean so i want you
to get a second opinion if the net
result is that you can get a fix for 3
000 would i fix a 5600 car for 3 000 no
i would not i'd sell it
okay so you have the 4 000 you have the
4 000
do you have the 4 000 to fix the car
yes put that with the money you get from
selling the car as is and buy you
another car
because you're probably going to get
1600 for it as is
or
do you better it's better to just list
it as is with the issues and see what i
can get for it i think you'll get couple
thousand bucks for it
and you put that with four thousand
bucks you've got a six thousand dollar
car that's not broken
i would do that before i'd spend four
thousand dollars on a six thousand
dollar car now i would get a second
opinion and i would quit going to the
dealer for major repairs until you're
rich
uh because you really can't afford it
until then what must be done for this
car to operate that would be the
question i'd ask with the second and
third opinion too yeah this is a hooptie
so
let's just hoop we don't need to we
don't need a race we get we tell folks
drive a cheap car drive like no one else
so later you can drive like no one else
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else pay a
price i drove a piece of crap now i
don't drive a piece of crap because i
don't have to because i don't have car
payments i never had car payments in the
last 30 years and that means i have
money
whoa it's a neat formula
and so i did i drive a hooptie for uh
ever no i drove it for a year
and i got a little better hoopty that
really was not just a quasi-hooptie and
then i moved up a year later into a
non-hooptie and from then on i never
looked back and bought used cars until i
had a net worth of a million dollars and
i pay cash for my cars and anything with
a motor or wheels in it
because they go down in value i know not
lately but it's the one time in the
history of the vehicle that it has not
gone out down in value and it will
return people and that's not just a
boomer it's an economic prediction
called supply demand curve okay anyway
now what do you do if you're driving a
hooptie and it breaks a lot of our
people are driving thousand dollar cars
500 cars garage sale car right 2 000 car
okay these are throwaway cars
they will bring almost as much at the
junkyard not running
as they will running on craigslist
okay because it's a garage sale car and
anything 5 000 or under is in this
category
most of those cars you do not do major
repairs to no because it's not worth it
so here's here's the way the formula
works if you can sell the car in his
case for sixteen hundred dollars
and you put four thousand dollars in it
and the car is worth 5600 you broke even
if you could sell the car for two
thousand dollars and you put four
thousand dollars in it and you sell it
for fifty six hundred you lost four
hundred dollars
so if the value of the car as is
plus the repair
the actual repair not from a dealer
plus the repair
is more than the finished fixed value
don't fix it yep and usually if it's a
major multi-thousand dollar repair
that's what you're gonna find because
you're not increasing the value of the
car now if you've got a car it's worth
500 bucks and you put 500 bucks in it
and it's worth four thousand dollars
hey you'd probably do that one right